I've visited red States and blue States
and I found that the common values that
unite us are deeper than our divisions
and um I thought you might clap for that
I'm Dave Rubin
I thought you might clap for that this
is the Reuben report it's May 26 2023. I
am back in studio live we are live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
if you want to join us for a post-game
wrap-up show today
reubenreport.locals.com and we've only
got about 45 minutes for today's show
because I'll be joining Megan Kelly on
her show for the hour immediately after
and I think we have a little bit of a
difference of opinion on some of this
Trump Santa stuff and we're gonna get
into it and still respect and like each
other and drink tequila next time we see
each other I should note that I am back
and safe I was in San Francisco
yesterday that place is a complete dump
I know you know it but uh genuinely you
walk around that place and you do not
feel safe I actually ended up showering
before I went to bed or the other night
because you just feel absolutely gross
there it is such a perfect living
breathing
well I guess maybe not living because
there's a lot of dead people on the
streets but like quasi-living more
zombie-like living uh version of why
progressives should not be in power they
absolutely ruin everything but I'll
explain why I was there uh in just a few
moments uh the purpose of today's
today's show today's program uh is to
talk about the DeSantis campaign launch
obviously it was funny that I wasn't in
studio of all days to not be in studio
wasn't in studio yesterday but I really
had to go to San Francisco for a good
reason met with some guy you might have
heard of
um but DeSantis has announced uh he set
record fundraising yesterday uh they
obviously did this thing on Twitter
spaces we'll talk about that and the
launch and all that sort of stuff uh and
then we're going to get into some of the
Trump response on that and look the game
is afoot the game is a foot I hope to do
my best over the next year and a half or
however long this thing goes on uh
however long everybody's fighting to to
present all of this to you in the most
honest possible way a without hiding
what my feelings and biases are you know
for those of you that that still do
occasionally tune into CNN or MSNBC or
any of these things uh you know these
people are pretending that they don't
have feelings about these things when
they obviously have hyper feelings about
these things so I will try to present
everything honest as honestly as I
always do and also tell you what I think
about the situation and obviously I'm
I'm intimately involved at some level
and uh and I'm psyched I think it's this
was a long time of coming as they say
and it is finally here so yes Ron
DeSantis has officially announced his
candidacy to be president of the United
States here is the launch video that
went up about 10 minutes before the
Twitter spaces which we'll get to in a
moment
[Applause]
disaster
I'm infests our cities the federal
government makes it harder for families
to make ends meet and the president
flounders but decline is a choice
success is attainable and freedom is
worth fighting for writing the ship
requires restoring sanity to our society
normalcy to our communities and
integrity to our institutions
truth must be our foundation and Common
Sense can no longer be an uncommon
virtue in Florida we prove that it can
be done we chose facts over fear
education over indoctrination Law and
Order over rioting and disorder we held
the line when Freedom hung in the bounds
we showed that we can and must
Revitalize America we need the courage
to lead and the strength to win I'm Ron
DeSantis and I'm running for president
to lead our Great American comeback
[Music]
foreign
it's solid it's a solid launch look I
get it's a campaign ad let's not pretend
it is anything that it isn't anything
that it is it is a campaign ad but it's
solid I want to just repeat couple of
the words that he said there sanity
right we bring that up a lot around here
we're going to have a little dissanity
perhaps normalcy Integrity truth Common
Sense there was really no attack on
anyone there was one statement about the
president but it was really can we
return to something normal can we do
what is right oh and by the way I've
kind of done it right here in Florida
everyone knows it that's why everyone's
coming here and nobody's leaving and
it's clean and clear uh you know
remember the guy is 44 years old so it's
also a nice kind of refreshing to see
someone a bit younger that's saying hey
I'm gonna get in the race because you
know we've been stuck in this
gerontocracy which I as I always say I'm
not against old people I like old people
I still watch reruns of The Golden Girls
but it doesn't mean that a bunch of late
70s into 80 year olds should be running
the country anymore so it was just like
a nice clean simple ad right there but
really what the launch was was this
Twitter spaces so for those of you well
I suppose all of you now are familiar
with what Twitter spaces is but real
quick if you've if you if you're not
paying too much attention to the Twitter
Twitter spaces is basically their audio
sort of live radio show that they have
on Twitter so anyone you me anybody else
Elon Musk can set up a Twitter spaces
other people on Twitter can jump in and
then you're basically doing a live call
and show it's actually a pretty cool
technology they've had it out for about
a year it hasn't done like a major major
take off you know it's just sort of the
Insiders kind of use it in any event the
DeSantis campaign decided to launch on
Twitter on Twitter spaces with Elon Musk
and David Sachs you guys know David sax
he's been on the show a bunch of times
he was an investor in locals he's been
really one of the most outspoken people
against the Ukraine war he's co-host of
the all-in podcast
etc etc so he sort of moderated it it
was Saks Elon and uh sexy London
obviously Governor DeSantis uh here they
are discussing the policy to end the
bureaucracy you might know that as the
Swamp
I think there's a lot that the executive
branch can do and I all I will say when
it comes to these agencies we'll put
we'll we'll go into this a little bit
more as the campaign goes on but buckle
up when I get in there because the the
status quo is not acceptable
um and we are going to make sure that we
reconstitutionalize this government
the status quo is not acceptable well
that is right right we are watching a
completely out of control federal
government and the agencies and the
bureaucracy this is what we call the
swamp we are watching them spying on us
working with tech tech platforms to
silence us jailing the wrong people
looking into parents for showing up to
school board meetings uh chasing former
presidents with far nonsensical uh
attacks like the whole thing you you
guys get it the whole thing so what I
liked about that clip specifically was I
think it's uh thematic as DeSantis as an
executive if he says he's going to do
something he does it for those of you
watching this right now that maybe
aren't fully on the the DeSantis train
and that's great I want people watching
this that maybe totally dislike him you
don't even have to like me but if you're
tuning in that's pretty good but for
those of you that maybe aren't fully on
board yet tell me something that he has
said he was going to do that he has not
done he just completed it I mean it's
just true it's just true but I will
gladly hear the criticism on this uh he
accomplished every single thing he set
out to do in his agenda signed all of it
moved on the legislative season closed
and now he launched uh speaking of Elon
Musk and Twitter let's throw up the
image I happened to be in San Francisco
yesterday uh meeting that guy we're just
going to leave it at that it was
actually unrelated to the DeSantis
situation I didn't even know when we
booked the trip last week that this was
going to happen but it was a pretty cool
day to be there uh here's a little video
so that's just a little bit of a
throwaway uh here's video of DeSantis
saying that he is a winner and uh
there's a reason he's running
oh look uh I don't mind being called
different things I've been called
Everything But a child to God as it is
so that doesn't phase me and you can
call me whatever you want just make sure
you call me a winner because that's what
we've done in the State of Florida and
that's exactly what we would do
nationally not only in the election but
actually bringing all these great
policies to bear
that would be pretty refreshing right if
we actually I mean imagine if we could
actually do it I know I talk about
Florida on this show all the time and
there's there's a reason I do it not
just because it's enriched my life my
family's life but find people in this
room all the people that work for me Etc
et cetera but it's because it is the
beacon right if you're watching this
right now and you live in Portland OR
you live in Chicago or or you live in
Cali anywhere wherever you might live if
you're living in a place where they're
really not doing a good job when it
comes to cleaning up the streets and the
crime and the drugs and and you're
paying high taxes and your roads don't
look good and all of the stuff it's like
I want you to know and I think this is
what the real message of the Santa's
campaign is it does not have to be this
way it wasn't this way and it was only
until we let radical leftists run
basically everything and then we let
them into the White House and they
printed endless money and caused
inflation and caused supply chain issues
and now we have this crazy War non-war
all of these things but there has been a
place Florida run by this guy DeSantis
where it is working so there is a
blueprint out I think that's really what
this whole thing is all about and this
is the rubric that Republicans have to
use can you win an election and can you
win on policy it would be nice to do
both of those things not just win
because you scared everybody of the
other side or whatever it might be but
but win an election and also bring the
right policies to bear so I want to go
into a little bit of uh this is a little
bit of The Insider baseball this is from
Team DeSantis on some of the info around
the launch let's take a look uh
desantis's groundbreaking Announcement
by the numbers in politics winning
campaigns are focused on the metrics
that matter so here's a few hundreds of
thousands of people simultaneously
flooded onto Twitter servers to hear the
governor deliver the news for the first
time and crash Twitter's technical
infrastructure I'll get more on that in
just a sec Ron desantis's Twitter spaces
announcement Was Heard live by hundreds
of thousands of users more than 6.5
million have since listened more than
one million viewers watch Ron desantis's
30 plus minute Fox news interview that's
from the clip that we just showed you
Ron and Santos hosted a tele town hall
with over 82 000 live participants
Rhonda Santos's announcement video
earned more than 23 million views on
Twitter a million raised in the first
few hours of launch as some of the
country's top conservative bundlers are
prepared to burn up the phones today and
then just a little bit more on just sort
of like The Insider politics stuff this
is also from Team DeSantis DeSantis
raises record 8.2 million in the first
24 hours after the presidential campaign
launch Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
brought in 8.2 million in the first 24
hours following his campaign launch
shattering the previous record held by
Joe Biden in 2019 which was 6.3 million
the 8.2 million figure is a hard dollar
direct to campaign figure
uh We've also got a Fox News exclusive
over 150 former Trump officials back to
santis so when I got back from San
Francisco last night I went right to the
event the DeSantis event which was a
two-day event here in Miami uh and I met
some of the some of the donors obviously
the governor was there and the first
lady and the staff and everything else I
got one of these fancy hats I have never
been nor would ever take a dime from the
campaign let me be very clear about that
right now but I did get a DeSantis for
president day one hat so I've been paid
with hat and I have plenty of hats so uh
there you go
um what's good about this look you got
to raise money to win these things they
have they have very Deep Pockets right
now they are going to be in a war with
Trump there's no doubt Trump's got a lot
of money did you know that about Donald
Trump uh now I do want to address the
Twitter spaces thing because I was at
Twitter I was actually right outside
Twitter as the spaces was going on
listening on my my air Buds and then I
was upstairs at Twitter right after uh
with with Elon and uh and David Saxon
the crew uh there were some technical
difficulties up top it it took them
about 20 minutes there were so many
people flooding the system could they
have done more so that it would have
been a little smoother obviously uh are
they trying something that's a Cutting
Edge technology and there's going to be
some bugs yeah uh I don't think it
turned out to be a big deal of the idea
that they broke the internet whether you
think that's just now marketing or
whatever it's like it's not that
important the important thing is the
issues like that's really where I want
to stay focused for the next year and if
who is right about the issues and who's
talking about what's going on
politically and culturally in a way that
will get us out of this mess right and I
think that's what we're getting from
DeSantis right now it's like a serious
person like here's what I've done and
what I will do and here's why I'm going
to do it and that America you know does
not have to be this way and there can be
this comeback and all that stuff I have
to contrast that a little bit
unfortunately with uh with Donald Trump
here was what Donald Trump put on Truth
social as this thing was happening wow
the de Sanctus Twitter launch is a
disaster his whole campaign will be a
disaster watch and you know he uses his
capitals and whatever okay so that's
just like the usual stuff and it wasn't
a disaster actually if you listen to the
content of it and I recommend that you
do it was like they asked interesting
questions both sax and Elon a bunch of
people who've been on this show Dana
lash uh Chris Ruffo Jay bachari a whole
bunch of people asked interesting
questions across the board I talked to
sax after he 100 did not screen the
questions I was actually in there
there's a way that you can sort of
signal that you want to ask a question
they didn't get to me that's just fine
and I was going to try to ask a tough
question actually which I'll save for my
for my next interview with the governor
um but it clearly was a success uh
anywho here is a trump uh video
attacking DeSantis see if this Rings
right with you uh just see how you feel
about it
Ron DeSantis was struggling big time in
his primary race for governor of Florida
polls revealed DeSantis was failing so
bad he was losing by a staggering 17
points then DeSantis was saved by the
endorsement of President Trump
Trump's support was so powerful just
days after the endorsement DeSantis took
a commanding lead that propelled him to
being elected governor I'd like to thank
our president for standing by me when it
wasn't necessarily the smart thing to do
you're welcome Ron unfortunately instead
of being grateful DeSantis is now
attacking the very man who saved his
career isn't it time to santis remembers
how he got to where he is make America
great again build the wall then Mr Trump
said you're fired I love that part truth
is there's only one person who can make
America great again
I'm Donald J Trump and I approve this
message okay so I want to ask you I'm
actually not going to comment on it too
much I want to genuinely ask you person
watching this right now on the other
side of the screen like is that stuff
still working for you do you think that
Ron DeSantis owes Donald Trump
everything he did endorse him in 2018
and there's no doubt that that
endorsement helped him become governor
and then once Rhonda said this became
Governor he did the right things
especially during covid when Trump was
doing a lot of the wrong things he did
the right things and then ran this
incredibly successful Administration
that has led him to running for
president like what does really and I
think about this in your own life if
someone does something good for you
years ago what what do you owe them do
you owe them everything else in the rest
of your life do you owe them all your
aspirations all your dreams all the
things that you believe that you can do
if maybe they don't you know if maybe
they're just in the way and they want it
too like you just have to think about
that I think that's worth thinking um
David tax is texting me right now I
think he's going to give me a live
statement on on what his feelings were
about the Twitter spaces so hang tight
on that
um but the point is that these attacks I
just don't think they're working and I
think Trump kind of knows they're not
working uh Ben Shapiro had an
interesting tweet about the attacks he
wrote Trump's attacks on DeSantis are
his name's Rob so in a lot of these
posts he calls him Rob the Sanctus okay
I don't know so I don't know what the
difference between Iran and Rob is but
okay he has a bad personality I mean I I
just don't see that he uh here is an AI
simulation of a Twitter spaces including
DeSantis musk Hitler Soros and Satan
I'll get to that one in just a sec
DeSantis is too conservative on
entitlements hey wasn't Charlie Crist
great now you might be wondering about
the what the Hitler what now so Trump uh
right after the Twitter spaces we're
just going to show you like 10 seconds
of this on Instagram he put up a fake
Twitter space and pretended that Elon
Musk and Ron DeSantis and sax and
everybody else were in a Twitter space
with George Soros Klaus Schwab Cheney
Adolf Hitler Satan himself and the FBI
are we playing any video on that yeah
we're gonna play some video on that here
you go
hi everyone Welcome to our Rhonda
Sanders Twitter space Hello is my
microphone working correctly George can
you just wait while we hello can you
hear me we can all hear you George can
you just hold on for a second I don't
think they can hear me here you find
George just speak to me I don't think
George knows how to use Twitter hello uh
can you hear me now can I please make my
big announcement now everyone just hello
okay so like it might be funny to some
degree like I'm kind of personally
overthinking these things are funny and
and there look I love the meme Wars and
all of that stuff and there really was a
use for all of it but again are we still
gonna do that
or are we going to be a more mature
country are we going to say what's true
fight for what is good like actually
restore America or are we gonna just be
about memes and destruction and oh my
God here's a Twitter space where this
anthis is talking to Hitler
I don't know again this is up to all of
us to decide literally I don't like
collectivism but it is collectively up
to all of us if we are going to get out
of this thing that we have been in for
quite some time anyway now that it's
finally started you know it's
interesting because in the in the Trump
ad he's talking about how DeSantis is
attacking him and to say this really
hasn't said much about Trump at all he
really hasn't and when he has if you
read the book by the way do I have the
book out of the book on the on the desk
right now but if you leave if you read
desantis's book he's very complimentary
towards Trump actually and credits him
uh where credit is deserved but now that
the campaign has started DeSantis is
punching back here he is uh smacking
down Trump on Disney and immigration
Trump I think a lot of conservatives you
know we kind of laugh when you hear it
but a lot of conservatives believe that
a trump the Santas or DeSantis Trump
ticket is unbeatable real quick thought
on that and then we'll go into some some
of the other stuff
yeah you know I don't know I mean I
think that some of the things he's been
attacking me on I've been a little
surprised at because he's attacking me
from the left and that really wasn't the
Donald Trump from 2015 and 2016 I mean
he was a hard charger leaning in on all
the issues very edgy on conservative
issues and it was part of the reason he
did so well but when he's taken Disney
side against me I just kind of Wonder
like okay I get he wants to hit me but
don't take the side of a multinational
corporation that wants to sexualized
kids he's also hitting me against voting
against immigration amnesty there was
the good lat two bill in 2018 and he
said that that is akin to voting against
the wall but that bill was a two million
person amnesty for illegal aliens very
little money for any border security all
conservatives opposed it he did support
it as president which a lot of us were
upset about but to hit me for being
taken the America first position I just
think is a little little strange so I'm
not sure what his strategy is but I
think he's taking positions that are a
little bit different than uh than four
or five years ago okay so that's good
note it's not not a personal attack
right he's actually quite clearly
criticizing two of the attacks on him so
what are those two attacks he's
basically saying hey Trump because you
don't like me you're basically backing
and defending Disney which we know is
true right that's what he's been doing
and then interestingly on the
immigration one if you're not fully
paying attention to what DeSantis was
saying there if you're not fully aware
when Trump wanted money for the wall it
was also going to include that two
million illegals were get going to get
to stay here they were going to get
amnesty that is why DeSantis voted
against it it wasn't that he wasn't for
the wall he was for the wall but didn't
want that to also be attached to these
two million people staying here so this
this concept of trump attacking him from
the left I think is gonna this is this
is Trump if you're watching I don't
think this works I don't think this
works to be like I'm more of a lefty I'm
for more amnesty than desantises and I'm
for I'm more Pro Disney and even though
I was the one that was supposed to
destroy the woke when the guy comes in
and actually is destroying the woke I'm
gonna try to destroy him uh the other
one that that Trump has been doing is
really relentlessly going after uh
DeSantis over covid and I just
I I just have to say this in like the
simplest terms possible
everyone knows that Ron DeSantis was was
basically the best or top tier like top
three governors when it came to covid
everybody everybody locked down right
everybody made mistakes I've said it
many times I grant everybody a fairly
Long Leash you know in terms of what
they did and when they woke up we all
had all of us you watching this me
everybody we all woke up to different
degrees I was pretty good on 15 days to
flatten the curve on day 16 I was pretty
much there that was kind of early okay
Zip-a-Dee-Doo-Dah uh we all woke up to
different degrees it depended what state
we were in what level of draconian
lockdowns we were in and everything else
but everyone knows that the santis was
the guy the main guy leading the fight
to open up to get vaccine mandates get
rid of vaccine mandates to get rid of
masks all of those things as Trump was
still pushing them everyone knows that
to be true so anyway Trump put out a
video yesterday just going after
relentless going after DeSantis on covid
and everything else and I was watching
it and I was like man I know this will
take us 20 seconds to find a zillion
videos a zillion a zillion videos of
trump saying the complete reverse on
this and I was on the plane and I texted
Brock and I said Brock can you clip us
together a little something using
Trump's video that he put up just now an
actual reality and Brock said Dave you
pay me I will do it here it is
when the Rhonda sanctimonious facts come
out you will see that he's better than
most Democrat Governors but very average
at best compared to Republican Governors
who have done a fantastic job one of the
greatest
[Music]
but this is a great one Governor Ron
DeSantis how about the fact that he had
the third most deaths of any state
having to do with the China virus or
coven Governor's done a great job
Florida is down low now in the China
Byron even Cuomo did better he was
number four governor of Florida Ron
DeSantis who's done a
spectacular job in Florida he shut down
everything including the beaches other
Republican Governors didn't do that and
you're open and you didn't close and
you're just amazing perfect job he just
announced that the schools will be open
in the fall the Democrats blew it big a
lot of Republican Governors did a
fantastic job we're in a play school in
Florida and we have a great Governor but
no he wanted to show the fake news how
tough a guy he is enjoys very high
popularity and that's for a reason the
reason is he's doing a good job the
governor like Ron DeSantis of Florida is
doing a great job thank you guys that
was not hard for us to put together
Brock how how intensive was that for you
not hard Brock went like this not very
hard to the Trump people watching this
like I would prefer not to have to do
those videos I voted for Trump and again
I like Trump and there is a situation
where I will vote for Trump but if he
has decided that his whole campaign will
only be about lying to destroy DeSantis
that to me especially when it comes to
Florida and covid feels very personal
and a few people said that to me last
night that the the something about the
attacking of Florida that became the
beacon The Citadel of freedom in this
entire country and we still live in the
freest country in the world so if the
freest place in our country is the
freest place literally in the world and
if he wants to lie about all of that
then I have to text Brock and have Brock
put these videos together okay I have to
and as long as he keeps cashing the
checks he's good to do it you see the
point guys like it's too easy it's too
easy Trump there's a there is a lane for
you to make the case for yourself but
it's not just lying about DeSantis and
kovid and everything else it just is not
and then what you do is you make the
santis's job very easy because he can
attack you on all of that nonsense here
he is with Glenn Beck yesterday
I think he did great for three years but
when he turned the country over to fauci
in March of 2020 that destroyed millions
of people's lives and in Florida we were
one of the few that stood up cut Against
the Grain took incoming fire from media
bureaucracy the left even a lot of
Republicans had schools open preserved
businesses and so Florida since covid
has outperformed virtually any state in
the country when you look at all these
significant metrics
yeah again it's kind of easy and it's
true and look we can all play armchair
quarterback hindsight is 20 20 and all
of those things but it really is
important and this is one of the
problems I think Trump's going to have
with his own base his own base is the
most anti-vaxx his own base is the most
anti-fouchy and all that stuff but we
saw this one and I have to show this to
you because it's hard you know why I
always show you old clips because we
always forget everything right time
moves by so quickly endless scrolling on
our devices we forget things so quickly
but in in September of 2020 September of
2020 at the height of the election right
the Biden Trump election Trump was using
fauci in campaign ads as a positive take
a look at this it's hard to believe but
yeah it's true
the president has listened to what I
have said and with the other people on
the task force have said the first and
only time that I went in and said we
should do mitigation strongly the
response was yes we'll do it when He
suggests why don't we do this and I say
no that's really not a good idea from a
scientific standpoint he has never
overruled me the travel was another
recommendation when we went in and said
we probably should be doing that and the
answer was yes when I've made
recommendations he's taken them and then
another time was we should do it with
Europe and the answer was yes he never
counted or overwritten me and the next
time we should do it with the UK and the
answer was yes I never in the multiple
times that I've done that where I said
for scientific reasons we really should
do this that he hasn't said let's do it
the first and only time that Dr Burks
and I went in and formally made a
recommendation to the president
to actually have a quote shut down the
president listened to the recommendation
and went to the mitigation
it's hard to believe I'm surprised he
didn't get rid of Pence and have fauci
be his VP right like it is hard to
believe and again I am not doing that to
be heavy-handed right I am admitting
that hindsight is 20 20. but if if
you're watching this and you're the
hardcore Trump guy and you hate fauci
why didn't Trump figure that out right
and I guess we all have what limited
knowledge we have but to be re-elected
he was still pushing fauci he was still
pushing his pride in operation warp
speed and we now know that the vaccines
were basically a net negative right I
think that's probably being soft when I
say that uh and we do have to accept
that while guys like Ron DeSantis and
Kirsty gnome up in South Dakota and a
whole bunch of other other Republican
Governors were trying to open up camp in
Georgia who was fighting Trump trump was
trying to lock him down as he was trying
to open up Trump was still bragging and
very proud that he was shutting the
country down
we did the right thing we closed the
country down could have kept it open
I could have done what some countries
are doing I had to shut it down we did
the right thing I thought of keeping it
open and we did just the right thing we
closed it down and a group of very smart
people walk in say sir we have to close
it
and we did the right thing they can't do
anything without the approval of the
president of the United States even the
Democrats aren't blaming me for that we
had to close it up some people wish we
never closed it down we did the right
thing we closed it it's a decision for
the president of the United States we
did the right thing we had to close it
up because nobody's ever heard of
closing down a country let alone the
United States of America we had to turn
off the airlines we had to turn off
everything
and we did the right thing a lot of
people have thought about it write it
out don't do anything just write it out
and think of it as the flu
but it's not the clue it's vicious we
basically shut down our country you know
we did the right thing we had to close
it down the president of the United
States calls the shots and we had to
close it down we did the right thing
they're not working in offices they're
not in airplanes together and we did
close up we had to close it up and we
did the right thing we closed it down we
did the right thing we closed it up we
were told we got to shut it down stop it
tell everyone to stay home
because of this horrible virus and we
did that we had to artificially close
our country we've done this right and we
we really we really have done this right
that we did the right to everything all
right did we do it right do you think
lockdowns were worth it remember those
three years of abject insanity
like lunacy
he's very proud of it has he all I think
actually all he would have to do and he
could still do it he could do it even
today
Donnie if some of your guys are watching
the show I got a hint for you what if
you came out there today and say boy I
did make a mistake on that I really did
make a mistake on that and actually even
with warp speed I was listening to the
wrong people but he doesn't right he
very rarely has the Maya culpa so
there's every bit of evidence to think
if he became president again and they
bring back covid or monkey pox or the
zombie apocalypse or the Alien Invasion
that he would do it all again because he
hasn't shown any Contrition in the
horrific mistakes that he made DeSantis
by the way who did lock down let's not
pretend that he didn't he absolutely did
he has acknowledged that he wishes he
did not do it and he did not take some
of the advice and all that stuff now he
learned on the Fly it's really odd when
Trump's going after him on covertable he
locked down well you're very proud of
lockdowns but then he was waking up
quickly and has acknowledged it so I
would recommend for Trump to have a bit
of a Maya Culp on it I did make a
mistake with lockdowns and trying to use
the federal government to push it on the
states and I made a mistake with warp
speed and all that people will accept
that I actually think it would be quite
refreshing because it's something he
doesn't do but something he is doing is
siding with Democrats now which is very
bizarre here he is praising Evil Lizard
person Gavin Newsom and Cuomo who's gone
but whatever
you look at what's going on in
California where they're doing a
fantastic job they really are the
governor's doing great
proud of them I've gotten very friendly
with Gavin Newsom he's done a very good
job here I watched
what's been happening in California with
Governor Newsom and this morning with
Governor Cuomo and I applaud them
they're taking very strong bold steps
and I applaud them we agree on the
coronavirus and on that we've got along
very well and our relationship began
earlier than most and so from that
perspective all I can say is from my
perspective the relationship has been
strong it's been a really a terrific job
in California well we've gotten along
very well Gavin Newsom we've got very
well with regard to covid-19 as we call
it in that respect he's been fantastic
and we've been fantastic and he said
very generous things yeah California by
the way also doing a very good job
Governor Newsom yeah I'm going to meet
with the governor right now Gavin Newsom
we've worked very well all right again
these these are just reality things I
promise you over the next year and a
half I'm not going to bludgeon you with
all of this but I hope that by exposing
a certain degree of it I hope that the
Trump campaign will move on from these
ridiculous attacks because they don't
work and again you're you're operating
in a situation where your base which was
the most against lockdowns which was the
most against vaccines and certainly
against against mandates uh you're
operating in a situation where you're
you're at loggerheads with them you may
remember this one I mean this one is in
May of 22 so this is a year ago this is
a year ago right post postcovid
and Trump is still praising the vaccines
here he is praising vaccine manufacturer
uh CEO the Johnson Johnson CEO take a
look
also with us are some friends of mine
they wanted to say I said don't come
tonight let's go another time it's
pouring Woody Johnson a great gentleman
you ever hear of Johnson and Johnson he
owns the place I tell you what this
guy's got cash like nobody's got cash
Johnson and Johnson his incredible wife
Susan this guy's got cash like nobody's
got cash yeah because pharmaceutical
companies have giant government
contracts to force people to get needles
in their arms for vaccines that largely
don't work now I will acknowledge that
the Johnson Johnson vaccine was
definitely from what we can tell so far
not as problematic as the kids say as
the MRNA vaccines that came out from
moderna and Pfizer but nonetheless this
is a year ago this month he's still
praising Johnson and Johnson for covid
vaccines to his own audience that hates
it
that's fairly Wild
but there's another thing there's
another thing related to all of this you
remember the Summer of Love right when
the Democrats in honor of diversity and
inclusion and peacefulness even though
we were supposed to be locked down they
said yes despite lockdowns you can take
your mask off in Rampage cities and
Destroy targets and Pep Boys because
George Floyd has been killed check out
this ad this is a trump ad uh that he
put out regarding George Floyd just
since now that time has passed how out
of touch this was and is
I understand the pain
that people are feeling
The Death of George Floyd on the streets
of Minneapolis
was a grave tragedy
it should never have happened
it has failed Americans all over the
country with horror anger
and grief
we support the right of peaceful
protesters
and we hear their pleas
the voices of law-abiding citizens must
be heard and heard very loudly
we will stand with the family of George
Floyd with the peaceful protesters and
with every law-abiding citizen who wants
decency civility Safety and Security
but what we are now seeing on the
streets of our cities has nothing to do
with Justice or with peace
the memory of George Floyd is being
Dishonored by rioters looters and
anarchists
the violence all right the ad continues
we're not going to rub you over the head
with it and by the end there and I
wanted to show you the part where it's
switched by the end there he was getting
it right right like the violence is not
acceptable blah blah blah but the the
offering the peace offering to these
people who where we knew this was
obviously going to go the entire thing
uh was set up to take out Trump uh and
that he tried to play along with it like
they kind of duped him meaning BLM and
the entire machine related to George
Floyd and all that they kind of duped
him as well it just is the truth anyway
let's let's move on uh because this
video this guy I saw this this morning I
think this is yesterday while DeSantis
is breaking records when it comes to
fundraising and the campaign launches is
clearly people are paying attention and
it feels like it's leveling up uh Trump
is playing golf that's just what he's
doing uh he was asked while on the golf
course uh about desantis's launch and
well whether he'll debate him uh take a
look
if you were on a debate stage with
Rhonda santis what would you say to him
what would be your interactions with him
Adam Putnam beat him I don't I don't
know but they say he's not a very good
debater but maybe he is I don't know
we'll find out maybe we'll find out
Because unless it gets close why would
anybody
I believe that's what Trump would call
low energy
um the idea that Charlie Chris beat the
sadness in that debate is completely
ludicrous I actually agree desantis's
strong suit is not necessarily debating
it's governing but he did not lose to
Charlie Chris it's just sort of
ridiculous the more interesting part of
that is this thing about whether Trump
will debate or not right like if this is
supposed to be your strong suit you're
Donald Trump you're the TV star you're
Mr off the cuff I don't need a a
teleprompter I don't need a script blah
blah blah you should fully be ready to
debate and excited to debate so I I
sense there's like a real shift in
things I think the last two days
something has really shifted I think the
Trump people are really like oh man this
thing is bigger than we thought our
attacks have not been working and
they've been they've been so
over the top that we probably are
regretting some of them all of that
being said the mainstream media really
does want Trump and that is very very
obvious right Trump feeds the mainstream
media he tells you CNN is fake news and
then he does a town hall with CNN he
tells you it's the failing New York
Times and then he gives Maggie Haberman
endless access and they love it because
what does it do it gets them ratings and
when they get ratings and Views they get
money so this is really wild I saw this
video on Twitter a trump was mentioned
yesterday on CNN from what were the time
stamps on this from like within an
eight-hour span something like that what
is it 9 A.M to 6 p.m from 9 A.M to 6 p.m
you know how many times they said the
name Trump
399 times here's just a little snippet
hello and welcome to inside politics
let's start with Donald Trump Donald
Trump now of course Donald Trump trump
Donald Trump trump appointed Donald
Trump well that's interesting because
Trump Trump trump president Trump Donald
Trump trump Donald Trump Donald Trump
has been president president Trump
Caitlyn where are we right now in this
sentencing proceeding
Donald Trump Trump trump we have a
Donald Trump Donald Trump when it comes
to Donald Trump trump and uh Trump
Donald Trump missing from that is Donald
Trump you know Trump trump focus on
Donald Trump Trump trumpism trump a lot
of trump all right so 399 times and you
might go well why are they doing that I
thought they hate Trump I think I just
laid it out and you get it they want
Trump for a couple reasons it's not just
for the clicks and the views but I
firmly believe that they believe Trump
is the more beatable candidate and
DeSantis is refusing to play ball with
them uh here is a journalist by the name
of Jennifer Jennifer Palmieri on MSNBC
saying that Trump is more electable than
DeSantis do you think she might want to
push that notion so that Trump gets
nominated and then loses do you think
are you a wizard take a look
definitely no touch there's no
calibration with the guy and it's like
he started off you know he could have
just been an effective governor of
Florida and be doing well with the
Republican voters that want to move on
from Trump but instead he like re just
like double triple quadruple down on a
very mean-spirited
pretty nasty Maga agenda that I don't
think you know I mean
six-week abortion ban what are you doing
I'm not sure I think I could argue
Donald Trump is more electable than Ron
DeSantis when you support a six-week
abortion ban and his whole thing is
supposed to be he's the electable one I
mean that alone but then the totality of
the nastiness of that Maga agenda
marginalizing kids putting migrants sure
we should all we should the border is a
national problem and all all of us
should all of us agree all of us should
um you know partake in in dealing with
that you see guys they can't even hide
it they're saying the quiet part out
loud first off this idea that the
scientist is somehow nasty like it's
just it's just so ridiculous and that
somehow he's the one going after kids
he's the one stopping these butchers
from chopping the genitals off kids I
would say that's fairly Pro kid now she
might be right because I try to give the
devil his due she might be right that
the six-week abortion ban might hurt
DeSantis in the general it might I think
it helps him in the primaries because
he's you know right like the the base
wants less abortion so that might work
then in the general it might not work
just look at the the midterms last
November
um but this they're telling you the the
thing that they shouldn't that they
usually wouldn't be telling you which is
we want Trump so DeSantis is nasty
DeSantis is going after kids DeSantis is
the really anti-abortion whack job and
all of that stuff but the only reason
they're saying it is because they know
Trump is more beatable and here is a
clip of noted racist
Joy Reed on the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC calling Elon
Musk and Ron DeSantis fascists and
authoritarians what
for Elon this time
this is the person DeSantis most
identifies with these days they share an
ideology that seems libertarian on the
surface meaning certain people basically
people who look like Elon Musk and Ron
DeSantis get the freedom to do or say
whatever I want whatever I want no
matter how racist cruel or offensive no
censorship no masks my buddy my choice
but for you it's pure authoritarianism
wokism is dangerous fascism though free
speech
she's really just a terrible person like
I don't know how you analyze this with
like more thought put into it than that
she's a liar and she's actually a racist
and all that stuff Elon Musk for his
entire life he was pretty I actually
mentioned this to him in the meeting
that we had I said something about how
you were a lefty most of your life and
he he responds he's like you know that's
what everyone thinks he was like he's
like actually I was just kind of
apolitical my entire life but by default
factory setting default he was voting
for Democrats his entire life so he's
certainly he's not a fascist or an
authoritarian or anything else and if
you're paying attention to what he's
done on Twitter all he's done is take
away censorship there you know how many
people say horrible things about him all
day horrible things about me horrible
things about DeSantis yeah okay fine it
is what it is you can block them or you
don't even have to open the app it's
really wild so why is the corporate
press and Trump going after DeSantis
well it's obvious it's obvious that he
is the real threat uh here's a little
video of DeSantis and Elon because I
think this is a nice way to cap the show
on what this perhaps is all about
um we're absolutely committed to freedom
of speech on Level Playing Field and
just a vigorous debate and hopefully
this can be a platform that brings
people of Divergent political views to
exchange those views and and perhaps
some Minds will be changed one way or
the other and um but it's just
incredibly important as you as you
highlight that the the first amendment
is irrelevant if all the media and all
the and the government are operating in
lockstep it's uh it makes you know the
most important Amendment the one that
was most urgently added to the
Constitution
um moot if you if you can't have uh free
and open debate
um so
Twitter was indeed expensive uh but free
speech is priceless
great line right just absolutely great
line so you have to decide for yourself
is Joy read right when she calls them
fascists and authoritarians or when you
listen to the guys themselves how
thoughtful and decent Elon comes across
as he's defending free speech and bought
a company that is purging money left and
right and has a Litany of problems that
he's publicly talking about he bought it
for 44 billion dollars because he
believes in a plurality of voices and
free speech and everything else and then
somehow that same guy sees something in
Ron DeSantis that he wants to amplify
and you have to figure out for yourself
do you think that is good or do you
think that's fascist and authoritarian
uh by the way and then I just got one
other thing for you
um uh well you know what let's just get
into the to the David tax uh text so
David sacks was watching he texted me uh
he had something that he wanted me to
share I'm reading this on the Fly I have
not read it before uh from David sacks
he said here are my observations about
the last two days one The Descent
dentist space is up to 9.7 million
listeners 3.9 million listeners directly
in the space plus another 5.8 in Mario
Nawa Falls space which played my space
it's in in its entirety and then
commented on it so it was basically
another space that just took it and and
sort of repurposed it two New York Times
refused to acular accurately report the
numbers even after I provided them I
think they hate DeSantis more than Trump
I know they hate Trump too but I think
they know that Trump gives them more to
work with with uh more to work with than
DeSantis hence they're weirdly in the
tank for Trump for the moment three
Trump has lots of attacks on DeSantis
but unlike the mainstream media he has
not attacked him for doing the Twitter
space this is a man who understands
ratings four Benny Johnson reported that
Trump feels compelled to make a return
to Twitter after the DeSantis event
again this is a man who understands
ratings 5. Fox News shows that it is a
rate of Twitter with their coverage over
the last couple days which was largely
the same as the mainstream media I do
appreciate Laura and Kennedy having me
on giving me a chance to correct the
record but most of the hosts were
reading from the same script they even
attacked the space for not having video
which is a technologically illiterate
comment since it's not supposed to have
video I would encourage our friends at
Fox to see Twitter as an entirely
different medium one that they can use
to promote their Clips rather than the
competition but I suspect the Tucker
thing has them tilted okay so that's
from David sacks just kind of on the fly
as he was watching this show and look
that's what this is all about right like
you can there are such parallels here
from where I sit it's like we can have
the old world which is Trump and CNN and
the New York Times or we could have a
new world that say is DeSantis and
Twitter like we can just decide which
way we want to go with all of this but
it feels like it's being born there is a
chance now guys and we just gotta keep a
push in
did I say anything funny on today's show
well I guess I said the thing about
paying your checks and frankly I'm not
going to sign it this week and we'll see
what happens uh all right we got a super
quick post game show because then I'm
joining Megan Kelly on her show in just
a sec so reubenreport.locals.com part
two of my interview with Sean Spicer is
up across platforms both things already
on locals quick cold close for you and
we'll see everybody else tomorrow
on the way
I really need your life
[Music]
thank you